tell your daughters of this year
how we woke needing coffee but
discovered instead cadavers strewn about
our morning papers waterlogged
facsimiles of our sisters
spouses small children say to your baby
of this year when she asks as she
certainly should
tell her it was too late coming admit
even in the year we leased
freedom we didn't own it outright there
were still laws for every way we used
our privates while they pawed at the
soft folds of us
grabbed with no concern for consent no
laws made for the men that enforce them
we were trained to dodge to wait
to cower and cover to wait more
still wait we were told to be silent
but speak to your girls of this war time
a year
preceded by a score of the same so as in
two decades before
we wiped our eyes laced caskets with
flags
evacuated the crime scene of the club
caterwauled in the street
laid our bodies on the concrete against
the outlines of our fallen cried of
course
we mattered chanted for our disappeared
the women wept
this year they did in the same year
we were ready the year we lost our
inhibition and moved with courageous
abandon was also the year
we stared down barrels sang of cranes
and skies ducked and parried caught gold
and hijab
collected death threats knew ourselves
as patriots said we're 35 now time we
settled down and found a running mate
made road maps for infant joy shamed
nothing but fear
called ourselves fat and meant of course
impeccable
this year we were women not brides or
trinkets
not an off-brand gender not a concession
but women
instruct your babies remind them that
the year has passed to be docile
or small some of us said for the first
time that we were women
took this oath of solidarity seriously
some of us bore children and some of us
did not and none of us questioned
whether that made us real
or appropriate or true when she asks you
of this year your daughter whether your
offspring or heir to your triumph from
her comforted side of history teetering
towards woman she will wonder and ask
voraciously though she cannot fathom
your sacrifice she will hold
your estimation of it holy curiously
probing
where were you did you fight were you
fearful
or fear some what colored the walls of
your regret what did you do for women in
the year it was time
this path you made for me which bones
had to break did you do enough
and are you okay mama and are you a hero
she will ask the difficult
questions she will not care about the
arc of your brow
the weight of your clutch she will not
ask of your mentions your daughter
for whom you have already carried so
much wants to know what you brought
what gift what light did you keep from
extinction when they came for victims in
the night did you sleep through it or
were you roused
what was the cost of staying woke what
in the year we said time's up
what did you do with your privilege did
you suffer on other squalor did you look
away or directly into the flame did you
know your skill
or treat it like a liability were you
fooled by the epithets of nasty
or less than did you teach with an open
heart or a clenched fist
where were you tell her the truth make
your life confirm it say daughter i
stood there with the moment drawn on my
face like a dagger and flung it back
at itself slicing space for you tell her
the truth how you lived in spite of
crooked odds tell her you were brave
and always always in the company of
courage mostly the days when you just
had yourself
tell her she was born as you were as
your mothers before
and the sisters beside them in the age
of legends like always tell her she was
born
just in time just in time
to lead